every piece of information that we've
gotten in the John wick films about the
shadowy world of assassins has led to
another mystery
fortunately fans have been coming up
with explanations for confusing moments
and sketching out the history of the
world
here are the John wick fun theories that
could be true if you've ever gone
digging for fan theories then you
already know that the most common ones
some of which are actually true are
those in which two movies are said to be
in the same universe simply because they
have the same actor theories abound that
try and connect Steve Buscemi mr. pink
who escapes at the end of Reservoir Dogs
to his role as kool Showalter in Fargo
where he's not so lucky and you can find
dozens of other theories for dozens of
other actors and roles John wick is no
different although there's a surprising
amount of convincing evidence that fans
have come up with to connect it to the
matrix the theory imagines that John
wick is an identity given to neo years
before the events of the matrix in an
attempt to balance and correct for Neos
and the line desire to get out in the
matrix that's obviously getting out of
the computer world in John wick it's
leaving the shadowy world of assassins
behind for a peaceful civilian life by
putting obstacles in John slash Neos way
the matrix is able to keep his focus on
escaping within their false reality so
that he doesn't try to get out into the
real world and bring the whole thing
down you are working again no I just
sorted some stuff out it's also worth
noting that the connection between the
two franchises isn't just Keanu Reeves
one of the two directors for John where
could David leach worked as a stunt
coordinator on the Matrix Revolutions
a weak grasping at straws here maybe or
maybe this rabbit hole goes even deeper
all we're offering is the truth nothing
more it's difficult to think of the
reality presented by the John wick films
as well reality it's a world where
hundreds of enemy assassins connected by
a secret network of text messages are
lurking around every corner where people
can have gunfights in a crowded public
place without anyone noticing
and with fashionable suit jackets I can
stop bullets and you know there's all
those Mushroom Kingdom gold coins
floating around sooo if all those things
made you feel like you were playing a
video game where you're watching John
wick you're not alone nearly every
review an article since the movie's
release has mentioned the film's obvious
video game inspired action but
that's actually the points what if this
is actually supposed to be a video game
much like The Matrix fun theory this one
is mainly an attempt to explain why
there can be so much violence on screen
the regular bystanders and real cops
only occasionally react to the idea does
have some legs John himself does
actually make an official licensed
appearance in a video game
payday 2 and an actual John wick game
was released in 2019 if this fun theory
is true that pretty much automatically
makes John wick the first legitimately
good video game movie our apologies to
2005 s doom starring Karl Urban and the
rock better luck next time the world of
John work is defined by its Ross
including debts and obligations that
seem pretty impossible to refuse one
role stands above all though no matter
what the assassins are offered and
what's been done to them in the past
they have to treat the Continental as a
violence-free establishment or else you
know the room no business being
conducted on these premises lists
incurring heavy penalties we see what
happens to those who don't play along in
the first film when miss Perkins
violates our Continentals
well-established policy after the bounty
on John's head is doubled for anyone
willing to break the rules she gives it
a shot trying to take John out while
he's injured and successfully
eliminating another assassin Harry by
the end of the film miss Perkins has
sentenced to a permanent end with the
judgment carried out by a squad of four
people who surround her in all
directions it's a quick scene meant to
illustrate the price of crossing the
line at the Continental but the year of
tradition around it was very intriguing
for fans one fan Theory supposes that
the death squad is like much of the
wider assassin culture that we see in
the third film more ceremonial than
practical and based on centuries of
tradition with a reason because if it's
not one of the elaborate rituals we see
throughout the series it doesn't make a
whole lot of sense to surround someone
on all sides and shoot them there's a
very obvious reason that firing squads
here in the real world don't stand
directly in front of each other and then
fire at someone in the middle so the
only way the scene makes sense as if
it's actually based on an older
tradition likely one involving blades
and set of bullets if it was originally
done as a ceremony with swords then
adapting it to the modern world with
guns seems a little more logical
especially when you consider what we see
in Chapter three not only do we find out
about the longest
you have the assassins and their
formalities but we learned that somebody
taught John to be pretty good with
knives one of the many strikingly
strange moments in the John wick
franchise comes when we see the inner
workings of assassin bureaucracy and
find out that it's most these
secretaries typing on absurdly outdated
computers it could just be an unexpected
visual flourish to add some flavor to an
otherwise boring scene but one pan
theory makes a pretty compelling
argument that of course the assassins
would you see outdated tech it makes the
information virtually and hackable
although it's never been explicitly
confirmed in the films it seems pretty
clear that we're looking at some very
interesting information security modern
computers might be faster and have more
capabilities but it's pretty hard to use
a MacBook to hack a Commodore 64 and a
bunch of hard copy paper files
especially when they use rotary phones
and pneumatic tubes instead of the
Internet there's definitely some
connection since we see all those texts
going out but from what we can tell the
heavily tattooed administrators are
keeping things on an old school lockdown
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite films are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]